a couple of things actually inspire me
and they're odd of course one is the
opportunity and the continuing
regeneration of people in mid-career you
know when Bismarck set this retirement
age and the Social Security Agent
Germany at 65 it was because everybody
be dead at 65 and we'd never have to pay
anything off and as life expectancies
have lengthened what what has it's not
that old age is lengthened I think old
age and ability are still the last ten
years of your life which may start when
you're six who knows but but it's the
middle age has lengthened and and so
people are middle aged until they're
7075 some people are middle aged 80 and
so there's this whole second half of
middle age and I see an awful lot of
people in route good health making sort
of radical changes or full of
interesting ideas to one movement you
see certainly in the United States as
you see a lot of people going into
not-for-profit organizations and saying
all right I've made my pile I want to go
off and do this there's a you know their
consulting firms their head hunting
firms all oriented around around this
group of people so I'm kind of inspired
by an excited than maybe it's because
it's my age cohort to buy by the amount
of of ferment and optimism and sense of
a future and gee there's more stuff that
I can do that I see in that group I'm
really excited by the amount of similar
excitement and sense of opportunity that
I see in the people I met from emerging
markets of India and India and China the
in particular I get I've had a fair
amount of opportunity to meet some of
those people through the additions that
we published there and also just through
through through through life and related
to them they when I talk about these
middle-aged social entrepreneurs there's
also these social entrepreneurs in their
20s and 30s who are off doing astounding
things I think I'm excited by the idea
also that to get back to the topic of
leadership that we were talking about
that the leaders of tomorrow or the day
after tomorrow seem to be being formed
in new and interesting places if you go
back to you know if you ask where do you
look for leaders now or where our
leaders built now you might say the
military and PepsiCo and General
Electric and mackynzie and Procter and
Gamble and you'd come up with a few
places like this but you wouldn't come
up with soweto and not-for-profit
organizations or failed com companies or
or there's a sort of an interesting set
of new crucibles of leadership and and I
find that find that very exciting
you